Yes, this is super recent.
This just happened. It's not even cleaned up yet.
And if. If everyone who watches this,
watch it all the way through. Look,
I'll show you all the damage to my car,
and if you watch the whole video over a minute,
it will help me pay for my deductible,
because I am a single mom to four kids.
The only thing I did to deserve this was
I let a homeless veteran move in with me.
I was a bartender at a bar, actually.
He didn't put his ex wife down at the time.
He would say like, oh,
I have a disabled child.
I just wanted to make sure she would have the home
and her and the kids would be okay.
And I was fine being in between places.
I just, you know,
I fell on my. On my ass of. Anyway,
fast forward to. I had a falling out with the roommate that I had.
She left early. I had nobody to cover the rent,
and I was, like,
in a tight spot, and I was like, fuck,
I didn't know what to do. I was.
And I was like, fuck.
It's either, like,
a total fucking stranger or somebody that I know
and I've known for a while.
They're pretty good report with him.
I see him out all the time.
Uh, you know,
maybe this could be a solution for both of us.
And I asked him. I was Like, hey,
I have a place, blah, blah.
Like, I know you're a dad,
you have kids. Like,
we're in the same community,
like, whatever.
And I hated it.
And so I think he also thought I was gonna sleep with him eventually,
and I didn't. Like,
I had a boyfriend then. I still have a boyfriend.
That's the person I moved in with now.
And I think he was just, like,
really pissed that I never slept with him.
I never did any of the things that he was hoping would happen.
So I think he just has a lot of anger built up towards me.
And so because I moved out,
I only paid a portion of the rally.
You can see the other video,
but, um,
they even the claim suggestor was like, wow,
this is, like,
usually we'll see, like,
the street side busted.
For them to bust every single one of your windows
the way that they did was, like,
really malicious. So
hopefully you made it through at least a minute of this video
so I can pay my deductible.
Thank you. I love you. Bye.